Hey youtubers it’s charlie and the first
trailer for guardians of the galaxy just dropped
so I wanted to do a larger preview for the
movie with backgrounds on what marvel is doing
with the characters that’s different from
the comic books as well as breaking down what’s
been happening with their story up to this
point.
They really just rebooted the comic last year
and it’s totally awesome.
I’ll probably start doing marvel movie videos
every tuesday since so much is happening.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything if
you’re just finding me for the first time.
So let’s start with the characters.
We’ve got all the original guardians team
from the comics sans Tony Stark.
That’s right Iron Man traveled with them
in the comics last year.
But it’s Peter Quill slash Starr Lord, Gamora,
Drax The Destroyer, Groot and Rocket Raccoon.
They changed the makeup and the outfits just
a little from the comics just for practical
reasons, rocket raccoon is pretty close to
his comic book model.
Groot is the biggest change, he’s just made
to look a little more humanoid in the movie.
His comic book version is a little more tree-like.
The important thing to know is that they won’t
be a team at the beginning of the movie, it’s
all about them coming together over the course
of the movie.
The other heroes that aren’t part of the
guardian’s team include Yondu, Nova, Rhomann
Dey and Nova Prime, she’s the leader of
the nova corps.
Like the nick fury of Nova.
Now the villains, up at the top there’s
The collector, Ronan The Accuser, Nebula and
Korath.
There are a bunch of actors listed in un-named
or secret roles.
The most important is Sean Gunn.
He’s the brother of director James Gunn.
At comic con he said he’d have a really
important part in the movie, but wouldn’t
say what it was.
So he could just have been joking and he’ll
turn out to be a janitor or something.
But one of the biggest un-named roles is Thanos.
Because he’s such a part of the Guardian’s
stories in the comic books he will be a part
of the movie, but in reference only.
He’s not going to be a character.
It’s possible that he’ll be involved in
the post credits scene if it’s not Ant-Man
related.
The writers have said that he’s a galactic
presence in the movie, so he exists and people
know about him, but he’s not a huge part
of the plot.
The collector and ronan the accuser are the
main antagonists.
If you’re not familiar with the characters
or you haven’t read the comics in a while,
here’s a quick breakdown of the major characters.
Peter Quill aka Starr Lord is the son of a
human woman and the emperor of the spartoi
empire.
Also humanoid, that’s why he looks like
a normal person.
The character first debuted in the comics
in 1976.
Some of the character traits we’ll see in
the movie is his deadpool-level wisecracking
abilities and resevoir of 80s pop culture
references.
He’s a good analog for a smarter version
of Han Solo.
If han solo were the prince of an entire galaxy.
He’s the main protagonist of the film and
he’ll be the one to slowly round up the
Guardians and make them a team.
Then there’s Gamora.
You absolutely have to read the current comic
book run, because she is hilarious in it.
Not because she tells jokes, she’s always
the serious person that everyone reacts to
when she does something hardcore.
She and Tony Stark have this really funny
sexual encounter too.
In the movie Zoe Saldana is sporting red hair,
which is a little different from the original
character, but she and Drax both have green
skin so the color change just makes them look
a little better.
Notice that the color red is a big theme too.
From Peter Quill’s jacket, to drax’s tattoos,
to gamora’s hair.
I love the way this movie looks visually.
Originally in the comics she’s the last
surviving member of her race and is taken
in by Thanos and turned into a weapon of mass
destruction.
So part of her story in the movie will be
Peter Quill convincing her to cut ties with
Thanos and join the good side.
She isn’t any less hardcore, she just starts
killing bad guys instead of good guys.
I can’t wait to see Zoe Saldana go berserk
with giant weapons.
Green never looked so good.
Drax the Destroyer looks like Gamora, but
he’s actually a human who’s consciousness
was transplanted into a new body by Kronos.
He was created by Kronos as a weapon to use
against Thanos.
It’s unknown if Kronos is in the movie,
but when we first meet Drax, he’s on a prison
ship and Peter Quill has to bust him out.
The character in the comic books got retconned
a lot over the years, so they’ll probably
be sticking with the most recent version of
his history from the comics.
I’m really interested to see how they handle
the more supernatural magical qualities of
the character in the movie.
Or if they just wash over all that and make
him smashy like the hulk.
Groot and Rocket Raccoon are kind of a pair.
But Groot is also the only surviving member
of his race.
He can absorb wood to regenerate himself and
if he’s ever destroyed he can regrow himself
from a single splinter.
In the comics he gets blown up a lot and rocket
raccoon always sticks one of his twigs in
a pot of water.
He only speaks the words ‘i am groot’,
but that’s just what human ears pick up,
he does have a real language, but only rocket
raccoon can understand him.
Just like Han Solo is the only non-droid on
the millenium falcon that can understand what
Chewy is saying.
In keeping with the guardians motif, he’s
also a unique creature that was created in
a lab.
Pretty much all of the guardians except for
peter quill are the last surviving members
of their races.
He was originally a regular animal that was
given human level intelligence and bipedal
movement.
So that’s why he walks on two legs and uses
guns.
On to the villains, the collector is actually
like a celestial being who was born right
after the big bang.
So he’s ancient.
In the movie, Benicio Del Toro described him
as being like a space Liberace, which just
makes me laugh.
I think they’ll tone down his powers just
to make him more realistic.
But he collects artifacts like you see in
Odin’s vault in Thor.
At the end of Thor The Dark World the warriors
three give him one of the infinity gems and
he says one down five to go.
So it’s really the collector and not Thanos
that will eventually assemble all five gems
to form the infinity gauntlet.
So it’s possible that in the movie the collector
will actually be working for thanos or working
with him.
I can’t wait to see all the easter eggs
on his ship.
If you remember the original thor movie, Odin
actually has the gauntlet but not all the
gems.
I don’t think Marvel is intending for the
infinity gauntlet to be reformed by thanos
until Avengers 3 which isn’t coming until
2019.
Ronan the accuser is the other huge villain.
He’s the leader of the Kree Army.
He has a special legion called accusers, thus
ronan the accuser.
They’re like a slightly more sinister version
of the nova corps.
The Kree Empire will be one of the big antagonists
in general for the nova corps in the movie.
Because ronan is in the movie and the kree
empire, I’m really curious to see if we’ll
see the supreme intelligence.
They haven’t officially announced it, so
it’s still just a theory.
Nebula is another person on Thanos’ team
in the comics, in the movie she’ll be working
with Ronan the accuser and she’ll have an
interesting backstory relationship with Gamora.
Since technically they both work for thanos.
Unlike Gamora though, Nebula will be evil
through and through for the duration of the
movie, where Gamora will eventually join the
Guardians.
The other major villain is Korath.
In the comics he’s a scientist working with
Thanos, Ronan and the Kree Empire to develop
cybernetic soldiers.
In the movie I’m just expecting him to be
developing really sinister technology that
Ronan will use against the nova corps and
the guardians.
There’s still a ton of other stuff we can
talk about with the movie, but let me know
what you’re looking forward to most and
what your big questions are.
Since we’re so close to Winter Soldier I’ll
try to start doing Marvel Movie videos every
tuesday now just because I’m usually already
making SHIELD videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I’ll be posting my review of the full trailer
later tonight.
you can click here to watch it and you can
click here for my winter soldier trailer review.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!